ils sont des centaines à venir des
quatre coins de la france et de la
belgique c'est reconstitueurs passionnés
d'histoire qui confectionnent leurs
costumes eux mêmes sont venus redonner
vie à l'époque impériale au château nous
invitons des associations de
reconstitueurs qui reconstitue une
journée à la cour impériale au château
de rambouillet et qui est ponctué de
deux saynètes et de périodes de
divertissement assuré par des comédiens
des musiciens et des danseurs qu'on fait
cette année l'année 2000 21 l'année
napoléon c'est le bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon qui est mort donc le 5
mai 1821
vous pouvez voir un campement militaire
donc un bivouac avec de l'infanterie
vous avez également de la cavalerie une
musique mais également tout un village
civil populaire reconstituer jeux
d'époque dance music ou encore mode le
parcours des animations retrace la vie
publique mais aussi intime de napoléon
qui au total a séjourné 60 jours au
château de rambouillet c'est grâce à
cette venue où il s'est dit mais là il
ya vraiment quelque chose à remettre en
branle à remettre en marche donc il a il
a fait réaliser des travaux au niveau du
château est également la bergerie le but
c'était vraiment redynamiser l'artisanat
français à travers la laine un événement
qui rappelle aussi le passé historique
riche du château
qu'est ce qu'on a comme chance à
rambouillet d'avoir le bonheur de ce
château et de l'histoire qu'il porte
j'ai le souvenir personnel dit avoir
partagé un moment avec un président de
la république je leur racontais françois
mitterrand venait d'être élu maire de
rambouillet un autre moment avec un
premier ministre d'avoir accueilli
vladimir poutine
et puis un endroit où la garde bien nous
rendre les honneurs nous avions le
président mandela les 35 ans du jumelage
entre rambouillet et water loup était
également célébré ce week-end avec la
présence d'une délégation officielle